I think all life is suicidal I thought
up tongue-in-cheek sort of the madea
hypothesis Medea Jason's wife was
probably the worst mother in Greek
history she murdered her children
because of Jason's infidelities Jason
was probably not very good at anything
apparently except making women fall in
love with him it was good at that he got
the fleece back he wasn't much of a
captain he wasn't a fighter whatever the
Gaia hypothesis suggests that mother
Gaia who's the Greek mother will sustain
life keeps life going the colonel that
hypothesis is that life makes the world
better for itself that the regulation
and a number of systems life is
increasing habitability it's kind of
like I'm in a hotel right now and in my
hotel before I leave I paint the walls
and i put in a better stereo system or
something you know I'm making the place
better for my having been there well
that's really with the guy I hypothesis
suggests whereas if you really look at
the history of life on this planet you
see a lot of biologically produced
catastrophes and that's really what
Medea is suggesting that life is is the
global warming that starts the process
but the killing comes from the hydrogen
sulfide where's that come from that
comes from microbes from life itself so
life is the bullet if the gun itself is
the volcano
intelligence is the only way out I would
suspect that all life is inherently
Medea and the reason being if we think
of the definition of life it metabolizes
it reproduces and it evolves through
Darwinian selection that's the NASA
definition Darwinian selection means
that you produce more offspring than can
possibly live so competition is built
into life you compete not only with
other species but with yourself the
competition in this entire system leads
to one species trying to take over the
whole planet that's built into every
species wishes it could be dominant it's
just built into the system it's part of
the basic fabric of life the only out on
this because the ultimate end result of
one species taking over is eventual life
or death of all life on the planet
itself the only out is intelligence
owning an intelligent creature can
realize how the system works then begin
the engineering they can keep planetary
life-giving systems like carbon cycles
nitrogen cycles all of those going
unless intelligence is there it's going
to completely break down and that's the
end of life on this planet